[Music]
finally tonight notable quotables
Charles Krauthammer style let me give a
piece of advice when there's a suit
between the the violent state of Obama
against the Little Sisters of the Poor
take the side of the Little Sisters of
the Poor it could because I was in my
youth of liberal yes I retain that the
marshmallow deep inside my heart the
pity is this this is the strongest field
of Republican candidates and instead of
our time they spent discussing this
rodeo clown I'm the best president I've
ever been that's a pretty low bar this
is what it sounds like when you're
living in a banana republic
every time liberals lose they accuse the
other side of all kinds of isms the
world is going to hell in a handbasket
little snow in hell before the DOJ is
going to go after her the hide Sean
Spicer witness protection program
somewhere in Iowa I think would help and
take away the president's tweeting
machine loser by far Melissa McCarthy
she lost old spicy and she will miss him
he didn't just lose a guy she killed him
you officially are putting a black chip
now on Donald Trump in Canada casino I
put the hundred dollars on Monday this
week and I left the ten dollars so I can
get really drunk you've been through I
want women in song all right
opioids I seem to have started the trend
the only other option is an act of God
and he appears to be otherwise occupied
right now make sure you tune in tonight
or set the DVR 9:00 p.m. Eastern Time
for a special event Charles Krauthammer
in his own words it is one I promise you
you want to see more than once Charles
at his finest we miss you